[Music]
good evening at welcome to tucker
carlson tonight it's hard to think of an
ideal more american than the freedom of
speech when people say our soldiers
fight and die for our values what they
mean is our freedom to say what we think
is true that's our birthright is the
most important thing we have that we
have ever had and so for generations
there was bipartisan consensus about
this in fact liberals were among the
most stalwart defenders of the First
Amendment and good for them but then the
left took control of this country's
institutions liberals became the
establishment they had once opposed and
suddenly free speech seemed like a
challenge to the highly profitable
existing order the one they were getting
so rich from so our schools began to
teach our children that freedom of
speech is a threat in fact it's immoral
and over time the kids started to
believe it why wouldn't they at this
point nearly 60% of young people believe
we should change the first amendment to
ban speech they don't like now changing
amendments is hard two-thirds of
Congress would have to approve a change
like that but on campuses many students
aren't waiting for Congress to act
they've decided to impose censorship
right now watch for example kids at the
purportedly
impressive Northwestern University try
to ban Jeff Sessions from speaking out
loud
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah that's Northwestern it's funny it
you know if you're a middle-aged parent
and you're at dinner parties with other
middle-aged parents and they're talking
about bragging really about what schools
their kids good - all right well you got
it you know Cody what's got into
Northwestern it's really the Harvard of
the Middle West I do you think it's
probably pretty impressive right no
that's actually what it looks like it's
not impressive at all it's pathetic
Northwestern by the way is home to what
they claim is that prestigious
journalism school and yet the student
newspaper there apologized for daring to
cover the Jeff Sessions event the
newspaper didn't quote nothing is more
important than ensuring that our fellow
students feel safe
the editors later explained as if
reporting was somehow a threat to
students safety meanwhile over at
Harvard the Student Government
Association on campus which not
incidentally is the single most
overrated collection of people on planet
Earth pass the statement condemning the
student newspaper on campus because
listen to this it had dare to ask the
federal Immigration and Customs
Enforcement Agency ice to comment on a
story they didn't endorse ice so I'm
just called up and said hey ice can we
get a comment now ice didn't respond
didn't provide a comment but it didn't
matter
more than 650 students at Harvard
Harvard signed a petition condemning the
paper for contacting ice the Young
Democrats at Harvard's campus issued a
statement claiming the paper had were
quoting now deliberately chosen to put
our students in jeopardy one campus
activist group is now urging a boycott
of the newspaper because calling ice was
just that scary it's pretty funny on the
other hand it's really kind of ominous
because our meritocracy is essentially
fraudulent and our system is completely
rigged for the benefit of a few a lot of
these shallow neurotic narcissists that
we're making fun of tonight well in the
end wind up running this country those
people writhing on the floor about how
they're so threatened yeah they're gonna
be in charge this shouldn't be but
because the system is rigged they will
be they'll be making the decisions that
affect you your life and the lives of
your
children grandchildren and these are the
people who literally couldn't care less
about the First Amendment or any
amendment or in fact any document that
might limit their power in any way they
consider themselves gods and they'd like
you to shut up and obey and they'll use
force if they have to so what kind of
place will America be when those people
take over